because there are some people who go
through
and they're like
um so statistically and anthropology
like anthropology
the highest quality of life is seen in
less economically developed countries so
people in like uh Nigeria and Ethiopia
are actually happier than those of us in
Western societies and they've got much
less and it's because you know the
little things mean more to them so it's
like we look at them as quote unquote
charity they have more meaning in their
lives we look at them it's like quote
unquote charity cases and a lot of
westernized people are like oh Africa is
poor Africa as xyzen it's like but
actually they're very happy they're very
happy with a lot less than what we are
and it's very subjective